d'un sujet très français c'est le
premier département à avoir franchi le
pas la haute marne a décidé de revenir
aux 90 km heure pour cela le président
du conseil régional il est passé outre
l'avis de la commission de sécurité
quelques irréductibles comme lui
pourrait franchir bientôt le rugby qu on
écoute l'argumentation de nicolas
lacroix l'homme de répondre aux attentes
des haut-marnais oui c'est électoraliste
quoi pas du tout ça répond aussi à des
questions mobilité en haute main dans un
département rural la seule mobilité
qu'on essaie le véhicule c'est la
voiture c'est vrai et on n'aurait jamais
dû en arriver là on aurait dû avoir une
vraie concertation avec les services de
l'état
on aurait pu travailler sur du 82 90 et
peut-être même du 70 ce n'a pas été le
cas ça a été fait de façon arbitraire
aujourd'hui c'était un juste retour des
choses notre réseau est fait pour rouler
à 90 sachets obadia c'est purement
électoralistes vous êtes utile ça je
n'en sais rien moi je peux vous dire
comme conductrice y compris dans des
zones rurales passé en permanence du 70
80 90 retour c'est difficile voilà je
suis parisienne j'imagine que les gens
qui tous les jours savent se conduire et
conduire sur ces routes là ce ça bien
quand même ce qu'il faut faire alors on
confondrait les chauffards non gilles de
neige c'est que nous avons une mortalité
mais la mortalité sur les routes
l'excès de vitesse bien au delà des 5 10
km et c'est aussi l'état d'ébriété qui
est quand même très important dans ce
pays
donc non d'israël état d'ivresse en
france c'est quand même la conduite en
état d'ivresse c'est presque dans
certaines régions la première cause de
délinquance dont un de ses motivations
non mais là j'ai pas dit dans quelle
région voilà donc je pense que les gens
savent quand même comment ils doivent
conduire et se conduire donc c'est
peut-être aussi électoraliste mais ça me
semble être aussi du bon sens voilà
marie visot ça rapporte encore les
radars ah oui parce que ces derniers
sont pas des mots ni ça rapporte
beaucoup d'ailleurs
dernière marquée par les gilet jaune a
considérablement fait chuter les
recettes je les ai plus en tête mais il
ya considérables ont fait chuter les
recettes de l'état provenant provenant
des radars
voilà donc après 80 90 je sais pas pour
le coup moi je ne conduis pas donc voilà
tout ce que j'ai vu passer c'est que ça
allait coûter 100 mille euros à la haute
marne de remettre les panneaux
d'indication et romola tafforeau meurent
couler du béton là ils nous ont bien un
bon accord a expliqué que c'était un
investissement pérenne ce que c'est
c'est un investissement qui a été utile
je lui ç'aurait pu être meilleur voilà
ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
moi je connais un peu les routes de la
haute marne et je pense qu'il est plus
prudent y compris agen de 10 conduire à
80 km/heure plutôt qu'à 90 ce qui blague
à part pose quand même là la vraie
difficulté il ya deux difficultés
d'avoir des règles pour qu'elle soit
respectée faut qu'elle soit simple ou
quels sont les mêmes pour tout le monde
et il faut qu'elle arrête de changer
tous les six mois parce que moi je pense
aux gens qui font le même trajet tous
les jours et qui en trois mois vont
rouler à 90 puis à 80 plus peut-être à
90 puis non plus personne ne sait à
combien on doit rouler sur les routes
mais qu'il fallait rouler à 90 vous
diront il fallait oui
après moi je considère que j'étais
depuis le départ je considère que cette
réforme était plutôt bonne
l'idée d'abaisser la vitesse on voit
très bien la différence sur les trajets
y compris sur les courts trajets on
gagne quelques microsecondes quelques
quelques quelques minutes on y compris
quand on fait au quotidien ma difficulté
c'est la manière dont tout ça a été a
été mise en oeuvre a été présenté a été
un peu stigmatisant pour les territoires
non accompagné d'ailleurs d'une réforme
structurelle notamment sur la qualité de
la voirie qui l'est c'est effectivement
aux conseils départementaux dont
certains sont exsangues qui n'arrive pas
à rendre leur route
je dirais carrossable normalement et
effectivement peut-être qu'on a intérêt
à y rouler un peu un peu moins un peu
un peu moins vite bref je pense que
cette mesure était une bonne mesure je
pense que on a nous les français un
rapport assez immature avec la voiture
et qu'il faut pouvoir le reconnaître
je pense que on a fait une d'énormes
progrès depuis le quinquennat de jacques
chirac sur sur ce sujet là que s'il faut
pas perdre cet acte direz vous fait des
ennemis mais mais j'ai pas de problème
et moi je compte je suis parisien donc
je conduis moins que ceux qui le font
les trajets au quotidien mais on a tous
aussi dans nos familles dans les
cimetières des gens qui sont restés au
bord d'une route un soir une journée il
ya un drame français autour de la
voiture je trouve qu'on en est sorti
dans les années 90 2000 et gilet jaune
était été au ciné c'est exact mais parce
qu'ils l'ont pris comme une sanction
parce que 7,7 cette réforme a été mal
présentée elle a été mal accompagné
c'était pas une réforme de sanctions
pour les gens qui vivent et qui équipe
et qui vont travailler en voiture mais
il ya un moment où entre la vie et
quelques minutes car on peut choisir la
vie et se féliciter que le gouvernement
porte ce genre de réforme du soutien du
gouvernement c'est pas un peu défaut
c'est sûr sur les départements avec
assez peu clair
baby s'il a fallu lâcher il a fallu
lâcher un peu le truc à un moment donné
donc mais il était coincé il ya eu une
dimension gouttes d'eau à travers cette
cette réglementation cette contrainte
nouvelle dans un contexte où il y avait
déjà un conflit entre les élus locaux et
l'état centralisateur un reproche fait
dans l'opinion à ce pouvoir arrogant qui
décident de paris de choses qui
exactement on a un peu joué cette
syntaxe aulas sait que cette oreille et
aujourd'hui conseil départemental en
l'occurrence la commission de sécurité
dis non non et sachant que les critères
sont acérés de la mesure la mesure la
réglementation nouvelle elle était
fondée sur un principe de santé publique
la vitesse l'alcool ça tue assurément
mais la vitesse ça tue aussi
et à l'époque on les chiffres circulait
on était censé faire baisser la
mortalité d'au moins 10%
on a puisque on rappelle quand même que
les routes qui sont concernées par cette
réglementation de vitesse c'est la
moitié du réseau routier français mais
c'est les deux tiers des accidents
donc on parle du réseau routier qui est
le plus mortel en réalité et
calculer on peut faire confiance quand
même à nos ingénieurs pour avoir
construit des modèles à peu près fiable
les calculs disait qu'en passant de 90 à
80 km/heure on allait faire baisser le
nombre de morts sur la route de 10%
encore c'est vrai que l'essentiel du
progrès a été fait sous jacques chirac
il ya 25 ans il y avait dix mille morts
par an sur les routes à l'époque où
jacques chirac décret de ça comme grande
cause nationale on est à cinq mille
aujourd'hui on est à 3005 on descendait
à 3 milles en passant de 90 à 80 un
autre chiffre quand même les morts sur
les routes les le coût de l'insécurité
routière
ces 50 milliards d'euros 50 milliards
d'euros ça rigole problèmes de retraite
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
allègrement et de toute façon personne
ne peut se réjouir en fait de laisser
des gens conduire rapidement et mettre
en danger leur propre vie soir donc il
ya en fait y'a pas de débat il n'y a pas
de débat
le temps gagné au quotidien un français
sur cinq
un français sur cinq fait 40 km au moins
quotidiennement pour se rendre à son
travail
un français sur cinq n'a que 4 français
sur 5 ont moins de 40 kilomètres et donc
le temps gagné au quotidien de 82 m pour
l'instant c'est certes pas très bien
alors mais justement le train ou le
métro c'est pour les franciliens ou
quelques urbain on était là on parle
précisément de ceux qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas gênés par les grèves ou plutôt
moins que les autres qui prennent
effectivement leur voiture voilà et
réduire la vitesse de circulation c'est
réduire les émissions là encore je me
souviens que les estimations à l'époque
qui avaient été donnés c'était faire
baisser de 30%
les voilà et est tout simplement le gain
sur le toit vous voilà vous êtes
chantera lors sa vie théorique parce que
moi je alors ils sont pas si sage que
vous nous internautes disent le 80 km
heure est uniquement passer à des fins
de racket fiscal nicole vu que les
recettes des radars sont dans le budget
on a compris que ce n'est pas pour la
sécurité voilà je vous remercie
non pas une question financière peut pas
uniquement mais l'ex n a pas parlé mais
ce que l'on y avoir une question de
répartition aux produits de ses de ces
amendes notamment vis-à-vis des
territoires je pense que s'il ya une
vraie question de répartition
péréquation mais la question la sanction
elle et elle est utile parce que quand
il ya pas de sanction il n'y a pas de
respect merci pour ce débat c'est quatre
débats passionnants nous nous retrouvons
avec figaro live en direct à
saint-augustin où la police a chargé
parmi les manifestants merci bonsoir et
je voulais suivre l'information en
continu sur figaro live
[Musique]